des lois et celle des affaires
européennes afin de faire le point sur
la guerre en ukraine et l'accueil des
réfugiés en france on compterait à
l'heure actuelle cinq mille réfugiés
ukrainien selon le premier ministre vous
allez le voir sur ces images jean castex
était en déplacement ce matin dans un
centre d'accueil parisien il a pu
échanger notamment avec les associations
qui ont exprimé un les difficultés
logistiques pour appréhender l arrivée
de réfugiés justement sur ce chiffre de
5000 ukrainien jours aux d'écouter le
premier ministre se tait ce matin donc
de réfugiés qui arrivent en france
maintenant est ce qui justifie donc la
visite de ce jour est évidemment en
augmentation est en augmentation rapide
ce qui ont été dénombrés officiellement
par la police de l'air et des frontières
depuis le 25 février on a un nombre qui
avoisinent les 5000 personnes sachant
qu' un certain nombre d'entre elles sont
en réalité en transit plutôt vers des
pays du sud de l'europe avec par
ailleurs vous le savez la spécificité de
celles et ceux qui veulent se rendre en
grande bretagne on va là 17h01 presque
17h02 sur l'antenne de public sénat nous
sommes en direct pour suivre dans un
instant l'audition de gérald darmanin
par deux commissions permanentes du
sénat la commission des lois et la
commission des affaires européennes et
une audition qui devrait commencer d'un
instant à l'autre alors que le nombre de
réfugiés qui ont fui l'ukraine depuis
l'invasion par l'armée russe le 24
février a dépassé mardi les deux
millions c'est ce qu'a dit le haut
commissariat aux réfugiés qui fait le
décompte sur son site internet et donc
on a vu je vous le rappelle jean castex
ce matin dans un centre d'accueil
parisien il a pu échanger avec plusieurs
réfugiés remettant même un
symboliquement des autorisations
provisoires de séjour de six mois à des
personnes qui étaient présentes dans le
centre
on l'a également vu échanger avec une
vieille dame qui était très ému de
rencontrer le chef du gouvernement il a
dit halladay lui ai dit je suis très ému
d'être accueillis ici et effectivement
on a vu comme cela le pré ministre
déambuler dans le centre d'accueil il
est resté au total pendant une heure et
demie le gouvernement qui a rappelé que
les particuliers pouvaient également
s'engager pour l'accueil des ukrainiens
il peut le faire grâce à une plateforme
qui a été mise en place depuis ce matin
la plateforme s'appelle je m'engage pour
l'ukraine c'est ce qu'a rappelé
d'ailleurs jean castex ce matin écoutez
justement le premier ministre à propos
est bien de toutes ces initiatives
citoyennes que l'on voit se multiplier
dans le pays a écouté nos concitoyens se
sont très nombreux manifester pour
manifester notre solidarité à l'ukraine
pour exprimer notre solidarité à
l'ukraine par des dons des dons massif
vous le savez mais aussi pour recevoir
pour accueillir des ukrainiennes et des
ukrainiens dit
1798 suis très précis places ont déjà
été proposées pour héberger des réfugiés
voilà 17h04 sur l'antenne de public
sénat d'un instant à l'autre nous allons
pouvoir suivre ensemble l'audition de
gérald darmanin le ministre de
l'intérieur qui est auditionné au sénat
dans un contexte très tendu un contexte
international où on a aussi beaucoup
d'inquiétudes pour les réfugiés les
associations qui ont ce matin dit au
premier ministre qu'elle était inquiète
sur la difficulté à appréhender les flux
migratoires venus de l'europe de l'est
et alors que je vous le rappelle le
premier ministre a donné ce chiffre de
5000 ukrainiens qui sont en ce moment
sur le terrain français jean castex qui
a dit que ce qui est clair c'est que le
nombre s'accroît rapidement c'est ce
qu'a souligné jean castex ce matin alors
qu'il visitait un centre d'accueil de la
porte de la chapelle et qu'ils étaient
accueillis par la maire socialiste de
paris il a vite dit que effectivement il
fallait que et bien on prenne en charge
davantage et mieux ces réfugiés il a
parlé notamment de la mobilisation des
places d'hébergement en france il a dit
qu'il y avait actuellement 10
1798 places d'hébergement notamment
grâce à la mobilisation des particuliers
et il a dit qu'il avait comme ça 5900
qui venait de ces particuliers 3600 qui
sont effectivement et bien mis en place
par les collectivités et 1137 par les
grands opérateurs
d'hébergement à propos de ses 5000
ukrainien inscrit un vraiment
l'information de la médecine est écoutée
à nouveau jean castex
le nombre de réfugiés qui arrivent en
france maintenant est ce qui justifie
donc la visite de ce jour est évidemment
à une augmentation est en augmentation
rapide ce qui ont été dénombrés
officiellement par la police de l'air et
des frontières depuis le 25 février on a
un nombre qui avoisinent les 5000
personnes sachant qu' un certain nombre
d'entre elles sont en réalité en transit
plutôt vers des pays du sud de l'europe
avec par ailleurs vous le savez la
spécificité de celles et ceux qui
veulent se rendre en grande bretagne ce
qui est clair c'est que ce nombre
s'accroît rapidement alors qu'à paris on
dénombrait quelques dizaine d'arrivées
au début de la semaine plus de 300
personnes étaient dénombrés chaque jour
le week-end dernier et plus de 500 ont
été accueillis hier
nous avons donc mis en place d'abord des
points d'accueil dédié là où les
arrivées sont les plus nombreuses
évidemment la gare de l'est à paris
aussi l'aéroport de beauvais la gare de
strasbourg et puis des centres d'accueil
mobilisant je le répète les services de
l'état les collectivités et les
associations pour avoir un premier
diagnostic délivrer les papiers tous les
services on l'a vu ce matin se sont
installés ici à demeure pour avoir une
prise en charge globale qui est donc
administrative qui est d'abord humaine
qui est aussi médical pour réserver à
ces réfugiés le meilleur accueil que
nous leur devons et ensuite pour les
orienter vers des structures
d'hébergement
voilà 17h07 sur l'antenne de public
sénat nous sommes en direct du sénat
poursuivre l'audition de gérald darmanin
le ministre de l'intérieur qui est en
train de s'installer au moment où je
vous parle en salle rené monory 1
puisqu'il est auditionné par deux
commissions permanentes la commission
des lois et la commission des affaires
européennes sur le sujet que vous avez
compris le sujet brûlant du moment
notamment en france l'accueil des
réfugiés ukrainien on a compris dans la
déclaration de jean castex qu'ils sont
maintenant 5000 mais que leur nombre
s'accroît et bien de plus en plus vite
sur le territoire alors comment gérer
cet accroc cet accroissement comment
gérer cet accueil des migrants et des
réfugiés ça va être toute la question de
cette audition commune qui est donc et
bien prévu dans un instant d'une seconde
à l'autre en salle rené monory voilà
vous voyez les deux présidents à des
images il ya jean françois rapin pour la
commission des affaires européennes et
françois noël buffet pour la commission
des lois et qui est donc en train
d'introduire cette audition sans plus
attendre direction la salle rené monory
la commission européenne suite à ce
jugement
l'institutionnel je vais arriver d'un
des conflits attention
nous accueillons cette après-midi
évidemment
dans le cadre d'une audition commune je
le disais pour évoquer le conflit en
ukraine et plus particulièrement
naturellement sur ses conséquences en
matière de migration d'asile et d'asile
cette audition je le rappelle à
l'ensemble des collègues qui sont
présents et ouverte à la presse et
retransmise en direct avant de passer la
parole à notre collègue au président
rapin je voudrais mentionner quelques
éléments de contexte
près de deux semaines après l'entrée de
l'armée russe sur le territoire
ukrainien le 24 février dernier
chacun sait que les combats
malheureusement se poursuivent et
semblent redoubler chaque jour de
violences en ce moment même les villes
de marioupol de kharkiv son ton poids
d'un temps ce bombardement et la
capitale kiev et est encerclé le projet
de corridor humanitaire à semble-t-il
fait long feu et la réalité des
cessez-le-feu locaux annoncé hier
reste encore à démontrer
s'agissant du bilan humain il ne peut
être établi avec précision bien sûr mais
il est une certitude il est lourd
continuera sans doute à l'horizon de
s'aggraver l'heure actuelle le haut
commissariat de l'onu pour les droits de
l'homme est en mesure de confirmer 474
victimes victimes civiles et 868 s'en
sortent un blessé chiffres sans nul
doute très largement sous-estimé
l'agression russe
agression que je qualifierais d'un autre
temps et au mépris de tous les principes
du droit international doit être
fermement condamné non selon ce qu'elle
s'attaque à un état souverain mais aussi
parce qu'elle fait ressurgir des images
que nous pensions pas revoir sur le sol
européen
des files interminables de réfugiés
fuyant un pays en guerre le commissariat
aux réfugiés des nations unies estime
que plus de deux millions d'uc
d'ukrainiens ont déjà franchi la
frontière des pays voisins et que ce
chiffre pourrait atteindre les 4
millions si le conflit venait à
s'enliser
l'immense majorité de ces réfugiés
rejoint la pologne qui a cueilli un
million deux cent mille personnes
selon les dernières données communiquées
par le hcr
s'agissant de notre pays de la france
le premier ministre a précisé ce matin
que 5000 réfugiés ukrainien était arrivé
sur le territoire national soit le
double du nom que vous aviez annoncé
dimanche dernier on le comprend en tout
cas on peut imaginer la raison
peut-être pourrez-vous encore actualisé
ce chiffre monsieur le ministre vous
avez régulièrement réaffirmé la volonté
de la france d'accueillir en europe tous
les réfugiés ukrainien qui se
présenteront la france a également porté
ce sujet au niveau européen s'est
d'ailleurs largement à son initiative
que le 4 mars dernier le conseil de
l'union européenne a décidé à
l'unanimité d'activer le mécanisme de
protection temporaire prévus dans les
dispositions de la directive par la
directive pardon le 20 juillet 2001 du
20 juillet 2001 ce régime fourni pour
une durée de 6 mois à 3 ans une
protection immédiate et collectives aux
personnes déplacées qui ne sont pas en
mesure de retourner dans leur pays
d'origine
il est plus souple que le régime de
l'asile monsieur le directeur en ce
qu'il ne nécessite pas d'examen
individuelle des situations mais repose
sur un seul critère de nationalité
cette protection s'accompagne de droit
notamment d'accès au logement social au
marché du travail
cette position d'humanité et d'ouverture
remporte une rare un rare consensus
politique et nos concitoyens y adhèrent
massivement il faut s'en féliciter
et je m'en félicite éthique personnelle
et bien sûr face à un afflux important
de réfugiés qui mettra probablement
notre dispositif d'accueil à rude
épreuve non pas qu'il en soit pas
capable de relever le défi mais parce
que les enjeux sont là en nombre tous
les cas toute la question est désormais
de savoir dans quelle mesure et par quel
moyen cette volonté pourra être mise en
application va être mise en application
en somme comment mettre nos actes à la
hauteur de nouveau
avant de laisser la parole à jean
françois rapin j'aurais peut-être deux
premières questions à vous poser de
quelles données disposez vous monsieur
le ministre sur le nombre de réfugiés
craignais a d'ores et déjà présents sur
le territoire national est seul on voit
quelle hauteur se nomme pourrait-il se
porter dans les prochaines semaines
pouvez vous nous indiquer
qu'elles sont quels ont été les routes
migratoires emprunté et et combien de
demandes d'asile de protection ont peut
être déjà été déposées la deuxième
question en quoi le régime de protection
temporaire était le plus adapté que
celui de l'asile de droit commun au cas
des réfugiés ukrainien concrètement
quelle sera la différence en réalité
pour les bénéficiaires
le conseil allez c'est d'ailleurs aux
états membres le soin d'appliquer ce
régime de protection temporaire où la
législation nationale onnaing et
craignent un détenteur d'un visa de
longue durée en ukraine qu'en sera-t-il
pour nous quid des détenteurs d'un titre
de séjour courte durée tels que les
étudiants qui ne sont pas concernés par
la protection temporaire et dans la
situation a généré certaine crispation
paraît-il entre nos partenaires
européens
la ministre ces deux points je laisse
immédiatement la parole à notre collègue
jean françois rapin
qui merci merci françois noël merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre nous aurons bien sûr des propos
comme avec françois noël
simplement peut-être des questions un
peu différente je reviens sur les deux
millions de réfugiés annoncée par l'onu
je sors d'un échange etc ambassadeur de
pologne qui me disait que chez lui en
pologne un peu plus d'un million était
et est arrivé et ça ce sont des données
propres au pays
des échanges réguliers avec mes
homologues
présidents des commissions des affaires
européennes des états limitrophes et
nous échangeons sur sur le besoin de
moyens
qu'ils ont bien sûr
et tout ceci corrobore à dire qu'ils
sont effectivement très inquiet de la
situation l'union européenne a déclenché
le dispositif intégré pour une réaction
au niveau politique dans les situations
de crise les pcr qui avait déjà été
déclenchée en 2015 en raison d'une crise
de la crise migratoire également face à
la pandémie le conseil s'est aussi mis
d'accord jeudi dernier pour accorder la
protection temporaire françois noël
vient bien en parler à l'ensemble des
russes les ressortissants ukrainiens qui
ont trouvé refuge dans les états membres
sur le fondement de la directive de 2001
pour une durée d'un an et renouvelable
une fois
bien sûr la question de l'aide sociale
des soins médicaux va se poser peut-être
plus que celles des vêtements
pour anecdote en wolof l'ovac kiki et à
10 km de la frontière ukrainienne
reçoit chez elle lui personne elle des
camions de vêtements affluent dans leur
pays mais qui n'ont plus besoin de
vêtements ils ont surtout besoin de
nourriture et d'eau et de soins de
matériel de soins médicaux mais aussi de
d'opérateurs de soins médicaux entre
autres des médecins des infirmières les
ministres ont accepté de laisser
circuler librement ces personnes dans
l'union si donc pour l'instant les
ukrainiens sont principalement
accueillis dans les pays limitrophes
françois noël l'a 10 à 1000 personnes
devrait être aujourd'hui en france mais
d'emblée je m'interroge sur la capacité
des états membres à accueillir
finalement ce flux de réfugiés et la
façon dont la répartition va se faire et
comment cette exigence peut-elle se
concilier avec l'impératif de sécurité
qui implique de ne pas renoncer aux
contrôles prévus aux frontières mon
homologue polonais me disait la semaine
dernière que les passeports n'était même
plus contrôler parce que justement
c'était trop trop difficile et que les
files d'attenté étaient considérables
dans quelle mesure l'agencé européenne
frontex s'est-elle mobilisés à cet effet
est-ce qu'on peut on peut y voir là une
une nécessaire implication de l' agence
frontex en pensant que peut être c'est
l'occasion de revoir ses capacités de
mission
et
avec quel mandat surtout et avec quel
mandat autre que celui des pays qui
accueille l'aj ans
si aujourd'hui l'ensemble des états
membres se disent prêts à accueillir les
réfugiés au créneau la question se
posera bientôt de leur répartition je le
disais la solidarité entre états membres
est un élément essentiel et faute
d'avoir construit parce que il arrive un
peu tard pour d'autres raisons le le
pack le pack migratoires qui pourrait
constituer quelques et recevoir quelques
outils pouvant pouvant permettre et
faciliter la tâche ne sera pas ne sera
pas prêt en tout cas sur l'aspect
répartition ce ne sera pas prêt donc
voilà il faut il faut vraiment que qu'on
ait une vision sur ce que les états
membres sont capables de faire
aujourd'hui et la façon dont ils
s'accordent pour pour le faire vous avez
estimé monsieur ministres la crise
ukrainienne retardé mais validé la
pertinence d'une approche graduelle
sur laquelle mise la présidence
française pour avancer sur ce nouveau
pacte justement peut-être boostera thil
s'était eurodac et filtrage aux
frontières extérieures solidarité
intérieur en contrepartie les
négociations entre pays tiers on voit
effectivement les polonais les hongrois
beaucoup plus impliqué sur ce dispositif
alors certains 19 ce ne sont pas des
migrants effectivement sont des réfugiés
et c'est une réalité
et une approche probablement
différente de la part des pays qui les
accueille
par ailleurs l'union européenne a décidé
de mesures de rétorsion envers la russie
donc à la fois en ce qui concerne la
coopération judiciaire pénal qui a été
suspendue et le renforcement du rôle d'
euros juste dans les enquête
internationale sur les crimes commis en
ukraine et enfin dans le domaine des
visas certains nos partenaires demandent
à suspendre totalement la délivrance de
visas à l'égard de la russie quelle est
la position de la france à cet égard par
ailleurs comment mettre définitivement
fin au système de passeport doré par
lesquelles certains états membres
octroie la citoyenneté européenne ase et
investisseurs étrangers les golden
citizen qui sont notamment un russe je
terminerai en évoquant monsieur le
ministre les difficultés que nous
rencontrons avec le royaume uni qui
touche particulièrement le département
dont je suis élu vous le savez les
britanniques ont refusé et ont refoulé
150 réfugiés l'ukrainien au motif qu'il
ne disposait pas de visa d'entrée les
envoyant à paris ou à bruxelles et bien
sûr aussi un haka calais je sais que
vous suivez ça de près donc pouvez vous
nous dire un petit peu comment le le
consulat temporaire qui a été mis en
place fonctionne et et quels moyens ont
été mis à disposition
et si notre relation avec les anglais
sur le sujet en tout cas la relation de
l'union européenne avec les britanniques
se joie
[Musique]
associé à des discussions âpres avec les
britanniques comme on peut les avoir en
ce moment mais on ne peut pas on ne peut
pas la nier ce sujet merci monsieur
ministre remercie monsieur le président
la parole et peut-être quelques
informations d'organisation monsieur le
ministre doit nous quitter et 18h30
c'est ce qui m'a été dit en tous les cas
donc
il a dit je vais l'aider à paroles bien
sûr d'après chacun posera des questions
qu'ils le souhaitent et voilà le timing
que nous avons tous le ministre
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs en excusant avec quelques
minutes de retard mais j'en avais
informelle à la présidence
d'abord je voudrais évidemment commencer
mon intervention devant deux commissions
pour moi aussi avec vous et comme l'a
fait je crois
l'ensemble des forces
politiques dire à quel point nous
pensons peuple ukrainien que nous
admirons le courage c'est le
gouvernement ukrainien on conseille
t ministre l'intérieur jeudi dernier
nous avons demandé au ministre de
l'intérieur il finit avec lequel je suis
régulièrement en contact que j'avais
reçu d'ailleurs à paris s'est exprimé
comme l'a fait d'ailleurs la présence
disent qu'ils ont le parlement européen
et on a tous pu voir son courage et des
difficultés avec lesquels ils résister
dans dans son pays je vois aussi repensé
pour les fonctionnaires de l'état
français qui restent en ukraine bien sûr
les diplomates je veux aussi penser aux
gendarmes du gign et aux gendarmes
qu'ils gardent l'ambassade et qui
parfois à sécuriser les convois vraiment
ce sont aussi de très valeureuse agents
du ministère de l'intérieur dans des
conditions extrêmement difficiles alors
pour répondre à vos questions monsieur
le président je peux être répondre en
quatre points très très rapide d'abord
le féliciter une fois n'est pas coutume
de l'extraordinaire mobilisation de la
communauté européenne au sens politique
du terme deux conseils des ministres de
l'intérieur ont été provoqués pendant
les crises ukrainienne à la demande du
président de la république puisque nous
présidons ce conseil dimanche en huit
puis jeudi dernier qui avons permis de
déclencher deux dispositifs très
important le premier celui de l'ibsr
c'est à dire dès le dimanche déclenché
cette plateforme humanitaire d'urgence
de la commission européenne à la demande
de la présidence pour notamment livré à
sa tombe de matériel que vous avez
évoqué la france y participe très
largement notamment par les avions du
ministère de l'intérieur de la sécurité
civile qui tous les jours maintenant
font des allers retours entre paris
entre la france et la pologne ou la
roumanie
acheminé plus de 100 tonnes
de médicaments de matériel dans des
robes à la frontière polonaise craignait
la frontière roumaine ukrainienne à la
frontière entre la moldavie que je ne
veux pas oublier et d'ukraine puisque
nous n'avons pas le droit vous savez
bien d'acheminer ces matériels et ses
médicaments pour la population
ukrainienne en ukraine c'est des
vacations des corridors sur lequel je
m'étonnerai pas nous avons donc beaucoup
de moyens humanitaires nous attendons
encore cependant c'est une demande que
la france a fait aux commissaires
européens notamment en charge la
sécurité civile des convois union
européenne qui nous permettrait
notamment des ponts et rien n est encore
plus vite encore plus rapide de façon
plus organisée encore notamment pour un
point exactement aux demandes des
populations qui sont dans les pays
limitrophes et pour canaliser aussi la
grande solidarité que chacun constate
dans chacun de ces départements
d'élections sur la question
de la protection temporaire je veux
répondre directement à la question qui
m'a été kim a été formulée
en 2001 la commission européenne a
imaginé une directive notamment au
moment de la période tragique du kosovo
mais elle n'a jamais enclenché qui
consistait effectivement a autorisé de
protection temporaire aux personnes qui
fuient un théâtre notamment de guerre
donc c'est la première fois que deux là
vont enclencher à l'unanimité des 27
pays de l'union européenne après une
journée de négociations le dimanche nous
avons donné cette consigne à la
commission nous préparait une
composition le jeudi nous avons
travaillé sur la proposition de la
commission très largement modifié par un
compromis politique au bon sens du terme
est proposée par la présence française
est adopté ce que nous nous félicitons
dès le sommet des ambassadeurs se sont
réunis pour traduire et pour mettre les
virgules ah oui fallait remettre et dès
le lendemain publication au journal
officiel de l'union européenne et 2
désormais la protection temporaire vaut
pour tous les pays de l'union de l'union
européenne cette protection temporaire
donc six mois renouvelable jusqu'à trois
ans et mieux que l'asile pour plusieurs
raisons pour les pays d'accueil pour les
personnes qui demandent
cette protection temporaire et pour les
conditions avec lesquelles il peut vivre
de cette protection pour les pays
d'accueil parce que les ukrainiens n'ont
pas vocation sauf évidemment
difficultés géopolitiques majeurs qui va
durer des années mais ne se sont tous
que la paix revienne en ukraine nous
pensons que l'échelle d'année ne
s'épanouit pas la protection temporaire
ne permet d'imaginer une solution malgré
tout politique à cette situation
évidemment militaire particulièrement
difficile et n'est pas comparable avec
ce qui se passe en syrie ou en
afghanistan et que des ukrainiens eux
mêmes ont vocation à retourner en grèce
ce qu'ils demandent en premier et donc
il nous fallait un système de protection
qui ressemblait à l'asile mais qui
n'était pas l'asile qui était beaucoup
plus loin à obtenir puisque la
production temporaire sera beaucoup plus
rapide vu que les événements que nous
connaissons sont soudain et sont
évidemment
était en tout cas imprévisible c'est
mieux pour eux parce que ils vont
pouvoir accéder à en tout cas en france
une prestation sociale l'adar faire
venir leurs conjoints et leurs enfants
s'ils ne sont pas de nationalité
ukrainienne
évidemment si l'on allait à juridique
ils vont pouvoir travailler et notamment
ce point est important puisqu'on sait
que notamment en pologne par exemple
hongrie il ya des très forte communauté
ukrainienne qui sont utilisés par le
marché du travail hongrois et polonais
est donc naturellement cette solution de
travail est largement utilisée ou sera
largement utilisée pour ses pays
frontaliers qui connaissait déjà une
forme d'immigration de travail ukrainien
et qui par ailleurs auront accès aux
soins voilà dos qu'ils auront le panel
si j'ose dire peut-être un peu compliqué
demandeur d'asile puisque vous savez
bien que tout le travail la question est
différente le troisième sujet c'est
évidemment que ils n'ont pas la démarche
longue
maintenant avant d'avoir leur demande
d'asile et puis la possibilité de se la
voir refuser mais pour répondre à votre
question 321 une demande d'asile en
auront été pour l'instant formulé depuis
le 25 février dernier de la part de
personnes venant 20h d'ukraine sur les à
peu près 5000 personnes que nous avons
vu arriver sur le territoire national
sous les 5000 personnes que vous arrivez
sur le territoire national d'abord il
faut bien voir que ces chiffres de son
sens du passé du nombre de personnes qui
sont en france pour la bonne et simple
raison que d'une part ceux qui ont des
passeports biométriques ce qui va me
l'essentiel de la population de vivre
pardon ukrainiennes n'ont pas besoin de
demander de visa et donc ton pas besoin
de se présenter à une autorité
quelconque et donc peuvent circuler
librement dans l'espace européen et donc
la police aux frontières qui nous fait
le comptage des personnes ukrainienne
alliance le territoire national dans les
aéroports aux frontières terrestres dans
les gares j'y reviendrai
perçoivent que ce qu'il voit il ya plein
sans doute de personnes qui sont passées
par territoire national où vont
rejoindre des amis ou une famille où une
association sur le territoire national
sans pour l'instant
être capable de dire le nombre de
personnes qu'ils ont sur le territoire
national on le verra après lorsqu'il me
demanderont la protection temporaire
mais pour l'instant ce ne sont que des
comptage fait par la police aux
frontières ça c'est le premier point les
gens ont pu venir et peuvent être
installés en france nous le sachions pas
ce qu'ils ont dans les 90 jours de leur
présence sur le territoire européen la
possibilité de circuler sans passeport
avec maastricht sont bizarres et puis à
tout ce qui passe par la france mais qui
ne signeraient pas parce que les
communautés ukrainiennes sont nombreuses
en italie où il passe pas par la france
promet on était dit quoique on en
reparlera les stein portugal où il ya
une forte communauté ukrainienne
également et puis en grande-bretagne
pour avoir la question de son sénateur
j'y reviendrai ce qui est certain c'est
que
ces passages sont difficiles à compter
d'un pays à un autre mais une grande
partie d'entre eux traversent la france
sans pour autant s'y arrêter bien sûr
c'est d'autant plus vrai que les
passages sont de diverses sommes
beaucoup à la frontière italo-française
notamment au péage de la turbie mais
aussi beaucoup à roissy ou à prouver
puisque les personnes ont pris parfois
l'habitude de prendre l'avion notamment
de pologne de roumanie pour venir
directement peut-être par la route que
j'emprunte hui on peut être dans les
temps heureux de vacances je pense aux
vols commerciaux low cost qui vont à
l'aéroport de beauvais et arrive sur le
territoire national par par ce biais là
il ya aussi tous ceux qui viennent par
train d'autriche d'allemagne où
désormais aussi par car et donc on va
dire que chacun se débrouille et que
s'il est difficile pour la police
française de pouvoir suivre exactement
ses déplacements même si aujourd'hui
nous avons eu effectivement une
publication grosso modo part de monsieur
le président ce qui explique et sheedy
fait rentrer dimanche et ce matin du
premier ministre de façon exponentielle
et un peu de chance que cela s'arrête
évidemment alors aujourd'hui nous sommes
actuellement à 10500 98 places possibles
pour accueillir c'est ces personnes
ukrainienne donc on est largement au
dessus des capacités par rapport aux
personnes que nous constatons 6000
particuliers qui ont offert une présence
de familles dans les foyers français et
3700 places des collectivités locales
qui pourraient s'en sont remontés au
préfet de la république nous avons écrit
dès la semaine dernière je vois que j'ai
fait parvenir aux parlementaires la
lettre que nous avons envoyé à plusieurs
ministres à tous les élus qui souhaitait
organiser
la solidarité de leur association de
leur propre commune des familles et les
maires sont en contact direct avec les
préfet mais aussi les présidents de
conseils départementaux au présent trop
serré jeunots pour offrir ces places
j'ai nommé à préfet le préfet y met en
charge la coordination de cette de cet
accueil bien évidemment et nous
apprenons tous les jours la ministre
déléguée marlène schiappa est d'ailleurs
particulièrement chargé à la fois d'une
plateforme qu'elle a mis en place sur
internet
qui permet à chacune et à chacun de se
faire connaître pour accueillir ces
familles mais également d'organiser les
choses avec les associations d'élus
locaux qui ont été reçus vendredi
dernier au ministère de l'intérieur
alors si les places sont nombreuses
aujourd'hui une corée sont pas saturées
au sens où le nombre d'ukrainiens vont
sans doute plus tôt dans leur famille
lorsqu'ils viennent en france et une
comme je dédie ce sont pas tous à
arrêter en france nous voyons bien que
la saturation peut arriver notamment sur
la plaque parisienne qui est la
concentration des gens qui attendent
elles bien évidemment mais aussi dans le
calaisis on y reviendra tout à l'heure
pour parler des anglais et donc je tiens
de réunions tous les deux jours place
beauvau à l'attention des directeurs du
ministère de l'intérieur indépendamment
des conseils de défense régulier que tu
as président de la république où la
question des réfugiés est évidemment
souligné de décision sans doute seront
proposés dès demain au conseil de
défense pour encore améliorer notre
capacité d'accueil pour faire face
effectivement soit à des phénomènes
d'augmentation de migration ne réfugiés
sur le territoire national et pour les
accueillir dignement soit pour aider des
pays qui vont connaître des saturations
pour ça la pologne on pense au sénat
moldavie l'attaquent de dessin va sans
doute faire naître un exode encore plus
important en moldavie est donc peut-être
peut-être des systèmes de relocalisation
même si ce mot est sans doute mal
approprié pour le cas pour le cas précis
ici alors j'aurai peut-être monsieur le
président corrigibles s'il me permet le
sénateur à pain puisque nous avons
souligné aussi que si nous devions être
généreux solidaire nous devons aussi
pouvoir garantir la sécurité des
personnes qui arrivent sur le territoire
européen et notamment le territoire
français et docile nous avons autorisé
qu'il n'y ait plus de contrôles de
passeport à la frontière ukrainienne
polonaise par exemple puisqu'elle ya
soixante ans de que deux voitures pour
passer nous nous nous avons pris un
engagement avec les pays concernés je
pense notamment à la pologne de contrôle
a posteriori donc quand ils arrivent
dans des lieux d'attentes comme on les
voit à la télévision il ya aussi une
vérification d'identité se pose alors la
question de la possibilité de garder des
visas pour tous ceux qui viendraient sur
le territoire hors pair et qui
n'auraient pas de passeport biométrique
ou parce qu'ils l'auraient perdue dans
la guerre tout simplement de travail ont
évidemment en europe et 1 à 7 à cette
question mais nous faisons des
vérifications d'identité
d'abord parce qu' il peut y avoir des
personnes dangereuses malgré tout qu'ils
étaient sur le territoire ukrainien
indépendamment de la guerre et puis
parce que nous voyons arriver là des
personnes extérieures à l'ukraine mais
venant combattre en ukraine habituel des
théâtres de guerre qui parier sur le sol
européen et parce qu'on n'est pas à
l'abri nos clés d'une attaque de
l'hybride comme malheureusement la
biélorussie lave est organisé et donc
nous vérifions et je peux dire qu'en
même temps que le faisons ces réunions
sur l'accueil des réfugiés la question
d'insécurité national du territoire
puisque de la dgsi et est là à chaque
année réunion est évidemment évoqué et
que par ailleurs j'ai de très nombreuses
réunions plus confidentielle avec les
services de police et et de gendarmerie
et les services intérieurs de notre pays
pour pour vérifier cela je me rends
d'ailleurs jeudi et vendredi répondu
présent des appliques en pologne en
roumanie j'y vais d'ailleurs en commun
de la ministre allemande de l'intérieur
ce qui montre sans doute la force de
l'europe de ce point de vue pour aider
de façon humanitaire comme l'a fait
ministre aux affaires étrangères pour
vérifier les conditions de soutien et
d'accueil notamment de dos meilleure
organisation et notamment au col
également de la venue des ukrainiens en
france on a peut-être une meilleure
coordination à faire encore en européen
quand les allemands savent que les gens
vont prendre le tram qu'on les accueille
bien à paris ce qui est pas encore tout
à fait le cas et que passant de
renseignement sont parcellaires donc il
faut que nous nous améliorons sur ce
point et puis aussi pour regarder les
questions de sécurité évidemment que
vous avez est bloquée et que on ne doit
pas oublier dans un cadre même de
difficultés humanitaire alors une fois
que je vous ai dit cela je réponds bien
volontiers aux quatre autres questions
vous m'avez posé la suspension des visas
lequel la russie pour l'instant n'est
pas à l'ordre du jour selon le terme du
président de la république on ne faisons
pas la guerre au peuple russe nous
faisons
nous prenons des sanctions sévères
contre ceux qui sont proches des
responsables de la déclenchement de
cette guerre donc larmes des visas avec
une arme intéressante comme le sont les
possibilités de gel voire de saisie
d'avoirs sur le territoire national
elles doivent être utiles doivent être
utilisées avec parcimonie cibler des
propositions ont été faites mais ne
correspond pas de façon générale à toute
personne russe sur le territoire
national par exemple les étudiants le
choix de la france n'est pas de
sanctionner des personnes issues du
peuple russe qui se verrait ainsi privés
de leur présence au territoire national
puisque nous ne sommes pas en guerre
avec la russie mais je peux vous dire
que notre sujet
recense
par sipa reçus par six minutes du terme
au sens détaillée du terme ça ça rassure
les visas pour les personnes qui ont des
responsabilités politiques économiques
évidemment ceux qui ont été pris dans
les sanctions européennes déjà annoncées
notamment les parlementaires de la douma
qui ont voté la déclaration de guerre
contre contre l'ukraine mais également
les autres et on pense évidemment une
partie des oligarques que coco la
télévision évoque très largement je veux
aussi dire que je pris dès le lendemain
du début du conflit une mesure que j'ai
demandé à toutes les préfectures
d'appliquer la prolongation général de
90 jours de tous les ukrainiens qui
avait un titre de séjour en france on a
dix-sept mille c'est une petite
communauté et que nous protégeons bien
évidemment elle que j'ai demandé au
préfet de ne pas ergoter
bureaucratiquement et de prolonger de
deux religions d'autorité leur présence
sur le territoire national bien sûr
s'ils le demandent et le sujet celui des
passeports doré qui est une pratique
absolument
inacceptable d'un point de vue européen
qui consiste comme vous l'avez dit à
acheter finalement un passeport européen
en passant par plusieurs pays à des
sommes coquettes qui a rapporté beaucoup
d'argent d'ailleurs à ce qu'ils ont fait
chypre ne le fait plus même si un stock
ancien record et malte sur la demande de
la france en présidence
jeudi dernier a annoncé qu'ils mettaient
fin à cette pratique également donc nous
arrivons à la fin des passeports doré il
nous reste encore à connaître ceux qui
ont bénéficié de ces passeports
qu'ils ont donc fermé pour l'avenir mais
qui existe pour le passé et donc nous
avons un travail très fort d'avoir les
informations à qui ils ont été vendus
pour pouvoir leur interdire l'accès au
territoire national bien évidemment
comme on le fait sur les d'autres
sanctions que nous prenons notamment
pour les zodiac frontex est très
mobilisé sur la question à la demande de
la commission et la présidence la france
y participe nous avons déployé notamment
des policiers en roumanie des policiers
français en roumanie notamment pour
protéger les frontières je me rends
d'ailleurs en pologne en roumanie pour
voir comment on peut améliorer encore
les choses nous constatons cependant je
veux ici le dire et les différences
parfois existent avec la pologne au avec
la hongrie sur d'autres sujets européens
dans les sujets qui me concerne mais la
grande le grand professionnalisme de la
pologne de la hongrie de la roumanie 2
slovaquie la république tchèque ne le
sait mais un peu plus en arrière pour
protéger des frontières et faire ça tu
m'as dit est donc évidemment nous sommes
tout à fait prêts à répondre aux
demandes aux sollicitations qu'il
s'agisse l'agrandissement de contexte où
d'autres toute forme de plates formes de
solidarité le président de la république
d'ailleurs avant que le conflit
craignant n'éclate avait évoqué une
plate forme de coopération
intergouvernementale qui existait déjà
dans le droit de l'union européenne pour
permettre justement tenir des frontières
en cas de problème dans une europe et en
dehors de l'europe on pensait d'ailleurs
à la moldavie et donc nous voyons là
tout l'intérêt des projets français
avant même malheureusement que l'ukraine
de ne connaisse le sort qu'ils
connaissent sur la question de la grande
bretagne bon c'est une situation peu
compréhensible de la part du coureur
devant français si j'ose dire encore une
bon que se passe-t-il une partie des
ukrainiens ont voulu aller traversant la
france en grande-bretagne rejoindre une
famille des amis d'ailleurs conforme au
discours du premier ministre britannique
qui évoquaient leur accueil sur le
territoire britannique il se trouve que
depuis au moins technique des plaques
notre frontière commune et une mère et
que ce soit pour y aller nous avons vous
connaissez une personne à tunnel un
accès sinon au port pour évidemment
l'aérien mais ce n'est pas le sujet
recalé à peu près 600 ukrainiens se sont
présentés à la frontière britannique a
calé trois cents ont été refoulés dont
une très grande majorité de femmes et
d'enfants
pourquoi parce que les britanniques ne
sont pas dans l'espace chénier et sont
sortis évidemment de l'union européenne
au sens politique du terme et donc
n'implique pas la protection temporaire
tel que nous l'avons voté par exemple le
jeudi dernier donc il faut qu'ils aient
des visas même avec les passeports
évoqué pour aller en rangs bretons il ya
ceux des ukrainiens qui ont fait cette
démarche et ils ont été acceptés autant
que nous le sachions et il ya ceux qui
n'ont pas fait cette démarche on peut
comprendre que quand on fuit
notamment lorsqu'il n'y a plus le mari
le père parce qu'il est resté au combat
ou parce qu'il est mort confie et qu'on
a fait 60 heures de route pour arriver à
calais pour aller rejoindre sa famille
passait de sessègnon en bretagne on
n'est pas penser toujours à faire la
demande de visa lorsqu'on était dans son
pays cela peut arriver bon et donc
nous avons considéré comme étant très
tatillon les quelques personnes qui au
début a été refusée notamment une
douzaine de personnes que la maire de
calais d'ailleurs avec lui et avec la
sous-préfète de canet que je remercie
puis on s'est aperçu que de 12 on est
passé à 300 pour vous corriger mais se
sait atteint le dernier fils et 300
personnes bloquées à calais j'ai échangé
plusieurs fois à gré ministre
britannique à bas prix tipa terre avec
les entretient une relation suivie pour
toutes les affaires que nous connaissons
en commun de très bonnes relations avec
les britanniques le contre-espionnage la
lutte contre le terrorisme de moins
bonnes relations celle de l'immigration
mais vous connaissez ce dossier aussi
aussi bien que moi la ministre
britannique semblait comprendre la
difficulté est donc m'avait fait part de
sa volonté d'installer à calais des
personnes britannique de son
gouvernement capable de pouvoir résoudre
ces questions
nous n'avons pas eu pour l'instant gain
de cause puisque ici il ya eu les
personnes par des associations mais les
personnes issues du gouvernement
britannique il le conseille surtout de
retourner à paris à bruxelles pour faire
ces visas bon c'était pas tout à fait la
demande la demande s'était qu'on puisse
installer un consulat de temporaire
nécessité fait loi pour pouvoir bien sur
trois y ait des visas et on comprend que
les britanniques veulent pas que
n'importe qui aurait sur le territoire
national cet affront stage à médine à
leers mais qu'on puisse arranger les
choses afin que les personnes
entreprises ne prennent pas leur voiture
après 60 heures de route avec femme et
enfants pour partir à paris ou à
bruxelles fin que pour avoir au consulat
des visas bon pour l'instant ce n'est
pas le cas malgré les annonces faites
donc après une première lettre rendue
publique
je réécris ce soir notre commission
reporte de quelques heures la réunion
que j'ai tenus ce matin puisque j'ai vu
une des vaches agitée qui évoquait ce
consulat à calais qui correspond pas
tout à fait à la réalité des choses que
nous constatons et donc je leur ai écrit
ce soir pour dix rames à un ministre
britannique ce que nous souhaitons ce
que nous voulons au nom des ukrainiens
qui veulent passer la frontière c'est
qu'on installe à calais 7 cette antenne
consulaire on est même prêt à leur
prêter la sous préfecture de calais je
suis sûr que la maire de calais serait
même tout à fait d'accord pour prêter
une partie de sa mairie pour résoudre ce
problème alors on nous avons des
discussions des britanniques j'en suis
sûr vont trouver une solution à cette
difficulté
l'humanitaire il n'y a pas d'autre mot
tout en respectant le droit d'accéder
évidemment avec des papiers au
territoire britannique nous espérons que
dans les prochaines heures cela soit
réglé parce que personne ne comprendrait
qu'on reste sur un schéma très très
bureaucratique dans ces conditions
évidemment pour chacune de deux de ses
de ces familles voilà ce que je peux
vous dire il ya aussi beaucoup de choses
qui se disent monsieur président sur le
nombre de personnes qui viendraient
d'ukraine mais qui ne serait pas
ukrainien et que nous accueillerons ce
territoire national alors il est vrai
que il y avait en ukraine pas que des
gens craignent un il y avait des
réfugiés eux mêmes d'ailleurs qu'elle et
de protection internationale et aussi
des étrangers qui visait naturellement
entassons régulière sur le territoire
ukrainien je pense notamment et aux
étudiants mais les quinze mille indiens
par exemple bon alors la première chose
qu'a faite la commission européenne sont
à notre demande c'est d'organiser le
retour de ces personnes étrangères dans
leur pays ce qu'elle a fait d'ailleurs
avec beaucoup d'efficacité je pense au
maroc je penserai à l'inde bien
évidemment il y a la question des
réfugiés qui ont une protection
internationale il rentre dans le coin de
la directive
protection temporaire il ya les
étrangers régulièrement sur le sol
ukrainien qui ont fui la guerre est donc
là effectivement c'est l'aider c'est un
choix des états soit législations
nationales haddock c'est le cas de la
pologne c'est l'occasion en briques
avaient déjà été prises et qui protège
également ces personnes de façon
différente de la protection temporaire
mais qui les protègent et conforme au
droit européen sur la protection
temporaire la france
a choisi d'appliquer la protection
temporaire mais sur les 5000 à peu près
personne que nous avons à connaître 4500
était l'ukrainien d'ukraine voilà donc
je pense qu'il faut contrairement aux
discours politiques de pouvoir entendre
nous accueillons effectivement tout ce
qui se présente et qui mérite d'être
protégée mais c'était évidemment
l'écrasante majorité d'ukrainiens qui
viennent le cuisine d'ukraine va je
pense avoir répondu intégralité nos
questions merci monsieur le ministre a
refusé la parole tout de suite au
président caennais qui
merci monsieur ministre pour une
disponibilité merci aux deux présidents
d'avoir organisé cette rencontre
de questions très très rapide
premièrement donc l'accueil de ces
milliers de réfugiés sur le territoire
national ne peut pas se faire sans bien
sûr la contribution des collectivités
territoriales
j'ai bien entendu qu'il y aura une
charge pour l'état au travers des
différentes mesures liées à la
protection temporaire ma question est
simple elle vient de plusieurs maires
que j'ai pu avoir en contact à savoir
est-ce que
les mesures prises pour l'hébergement
assuré par les collectivités
territoriales
qui se traduisent aussi par des aides à
la cantine par toute une série bien sûr
d'accompagnement liées aux compétences
communales est ce que le gouvernement
envisage éventuellement une contribution
à cet effort exceptionnel qui sera fait
par ces collectivités et éventuellement
si c'est la réponse est positive sous
quelle forme
deuxièmement nous sommes aussi
interpellé par nos concitoyens sur la
question des pastilles diodes
il ya une sorte de fantasme l'a acquis
en train de se développer dans notre
pays
chacun sait que on ne peut pas utiliser
ces pastilles n'importe comment et en
tout cas aucunement en matière de
prévention je parle sous contrôle de
médecins la matière néanmoins ici d'une
préoccupation des pressions qui sont
faites le sur les pharmacies pour être
très clair on bien sûr en espérant que
cela n'arrive jamais s'il devait y avoir
un incident nucléaire comment on a pu
connaître avec les vents de tchernobyl
il ya quelques dizaines d'années
est ce que nous sommes en capacité si
les choses devaient s'aggraver y compris
par des mesures
terroristes à l'égard de centrale
nucléaire ukrainienne est ce que nous
sommes en capacité d'avoir un stock
suffisant pour répondre aux
préoccupations des français sans vouloir
faire de parallèle bien évidemment je
n'oublie pas la question du stock des
masques que nous n'avions pas à une
autre époque problème différent mais
néanmoins préoccupations qui peut
aboutir à la même conclusion serons-nous
prêt au cas où il y aurait un drame à
caractère nucléaire dans cette partie du
monde
merci monsieur le président madame
laurence harribey
c'est la première question a été posée
donc je vais pas là la reposer
simplement peut-être la prolonger vous
nous avez dit qu'il y avait dix mille
places actuellement
et que donc on était à peu près autant
ce qu'il fallait mais vous avez cité
6000 particulier 3700 collectivités
locales qu'en est il de l'état ou alors
est-ce que c'est un parti pris de
d'avoir de faire appel uniquement aux
particuliers aux collectivités locales
et à ce moment-là ça renforce la
question qui a été posée par le
président caennais
j'aimerais aussi vous poser une question
sur est ce que quelque chose est fait en
matière d' intox sur les réseaux parce
qu'on voit actuellement une montée de
n'importe où et n'importe quoi
est ce qu'il ya un travail en matière de
cybersécurité en matière de contrôle
pour éviter la fabrication de de fake
news et surtout des
des événements complètement à côté de ce
qu'il faudrait pour garantir l'union de
tous par rapport à cette crise je
remercie enfin pour cette première série
monsieur jean yves le conte
monsieur le
président quelques quelques questions
pour plonger monsieur le ministre ce que
vous avez ce que vous avez indiquée
d'abord pour la protection temporaire
c'est la première fois que cesse et
s'est mis en place donc il ya encore
beaucoup d'interrogations sur un certain
nombre de 2,2 de détail et de deux
choses importantes qui pourraient être
mis en place mais puisque vous évoquez
la question des visas par rapport à la
grande-bretagne la france est un des
rares pays qui aujourd'hui continue à
demander des visas pour les passeports
qui ne sont pas biométrique ukrainien ce
qui pose aussi un certain nombre de
difficultés pour les ukrainiens qui sont
arrivés en slovaquie qui sont arrivés en
moldavie qui sont arrivés en pologne par
à varsovie et qui ne peuvent pas aller
en france
parce qu'il faut qu'il vienne à varsovie
demander à un visa est ce que nous
allons supprimer cette exigence
je pense que vous aurez des discussions
demain et après demain sur ce sujet je
voulais attirer votre attention sur sur
ce point sur les personnes qui n'ont pas
de visage de passeports biométriques sur
les personnes qui sont arrivées avec des
enfants avec tout pour seule preuve
d'identité de l'enfant à un acte de
naissance ou une copie d'acte de
naissance il ya donc besoin finalement
de deux normes et au niveau européen me
semble-t-il
un document qui permet de s'assurer
de l'identité sont bloquées l'accès à la
protection temporaire pour
quiconque quel que soit les documents
qui peut avoir aujourd'hui le jas tueur
aussi votre attention sur le fait qu' il
ya quand même effectivement plus de 5 %
des gens qui arrivent de
d'ukraine qui sont des personnes qui
n'ont pas la nationalité ukrainienne
et que les choses ne sont pas claires
justement parce que tout ça c'est
vraiment très rapidement mis en place et
que les informations qui sont données
sont pas toujours précise donc nous
avons en particulier quelques quelques
personnes qui se retrouvent en centre de
rétention en allemagne parce qu'elle
pensait qu'elle avait le droit de
circuler en europe avec les documents
qui avaient été remises par les
autorités polonaises j'ai vraiment votre
attention sur sur sur ces éléments et
sur l'information qu'il faut donner aux
personnes qui qui qui arrive parce que
sinon nous allons encore des difficultés
dans dans dans tous les sens je crois
aussi compte tenu de
2,2 de l'importance finalement du sujet
et de sa complication et de la première
fois que cette directive protection
temporaire et mise en place qu'il
faudrait en rappeler d'élèves les
principes généraux en particulier en
matière de de droit au travail et droit
aux circulations dans dans dans
l'ensemble de l'union européenne
parce que sur le droit au travail est ce
que la personne qui bénéficient
est ce que la personne qui aujourd'hui
rentrer sur le territoire de l'union a
le droit d'y d'y travailler ou est ce
qu'elle peut travailler est ce qu'une
personne qui arrive en france
aujourd'hui elle est directement le
droit de travail compte tenu de ce qui
est précisé dans la directive protection
temporaire voilà c'est me semble-t-il et
les questions qui qui qui qui mérite
d'être posée compte tenu finalement de
la rapidité avec laquelle on est conduit
à mettre en place ce dispositif
merci monsieur le comte notes et les
goulets oui monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre j'ai deux questions
la première c'est la coopération avec
interpol
comment est-ce qu'elle fonctionne la
deuxième chose c'est les risques de de
cyberattaques pas pour l'effectuer ces
genres de choses mais notamment sur la
fragilité d'un certain nombre de
logiciels
genre kaspersky qui sont des logiciels
russe est ce que le gouvernement a pris
des mesures en tous les cas préventive
pour essayer de protéger nos sites
évidemment gouvernementaux mais pas
seulement ça me semble être une un sujet
d'actualité puisque j'ai vu ce qui se
passait dans les pays européens et je
pense que ça ça nécessite une attention
tout à fait particulière jour merci
merci à la main ce ministre la parole
merci monsieur le président sur la place
et les hébergements
encore une fois sur les dix mille c'est
d'un premier une première remontée il va
avec la pression que nous connaissons
c'est à dire que les poissons est très
faible il n'y a pas de sujet en tant que
tel il va forcément
devoir être ce dispositif revue au fur
et à mesure des arrivées fur et à mesure
des du confit fur et à mesure des gens
sont poussés en dehors de leur pays est
en mesure d'assurer saturation pardon
des capacités des pays limitrophes ce
qui est d'ailleurs renforce l'idée la
protection temporaire les personnes qui
sont en pologne en hongrie ou en mode
avis il reste pour la sente dans ces
pays un très grand majorité parce qu'ils
ont envie retour de retourner très vite
évidemment dans leur pays tout dépendra
aussi de l'évolution de de la guerre
bien évidemment et on s'habituera
malheureusement à suivre cette évolution
mais lorsque j'indique à 3700 places
proposées par les collectivités et en
grande partie ce soit des places d'état
soit des places payées par l'état je
prends l'exemple d'une commune que je
connais bien c'est de tourcoing où dès
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs parce qu'il faut
décharger calais d'une partie
d'ukrainiens qui attendent les 10 ha de
la part des britanniques ben voilà le
préfet a répondu à la demande de la faim
l'appel de la maire de tourcoing qui a
dit nous on a un hôtel
que vous rencontrez vous dans le camp
bêta sur le sénateur lorsque vous
arrivez dans la jolie ville de tokoin et
cd dans l'état qui paiera des places de
7,7 de cet hôtel le ménage parle de
choses ça est très concrète ce qui m'est
arrivé arbitres et se met à envoyer donc
donc on dit 3700 tu as pris
collectivités c'est des collectivités
qui disait ben voilà nous on a ces
possibilités parce que les avions les
syriens ou d'autres populations parfois
été cueillis il se peut qu'ils dansaient
place des choses qui appartiennent
stricto sensu aux collectivités locales
je pense à des logements d'urgence que
vous les avez évoqué mais on évite de
les prendre pour plein de raisons que
vous connaissez pas ce que nous avons
propres sociaux dans notre pays bien
évidemment ou des gymnases mais ça c'est
une possibilité en cas de grandes
difficultés on a le sujet des centres de
vacances qui avait été notamment
utilisées dans des crises précédentes
voilà nous sommes si j'ose dire deux
jours chance puisque des vacances se
terminent au moment où à la crise va
être plus exposé en ciel on pourra donc
les utiliser néon ne l'imposent rarement
des personnes migrantes ou réfugiées
dans des communes sans l'avis du maire
on le fait parfois lorsque vraiment y'a
pas d'autres solutions notamment dans
les problèmes hivernaux mais quand je
dis 3500 places des collectivités c'est
en grande partie soit des places que
l'état à l'habitude de réquisitionner
soit qu'ils payent directement dans des
hôtels donc je pourrais vous donner je
dois donner au président évidemment le
détail mais celui d'avant ce jour en
jour et et je pense que je pourrais
peut-être à la fin de ce mois fera un
point plus détaillée puisque les
prêcheurs remontent seulement maintenant
cessé coordination que préfet du maine
va organiser à l'orangerie au sein de la
contribution de l'état n'étant pas en
charge et des collectivités locales je
me permets pas monsieur le ministre de
détailler cela mais j'imagine que
d'habitude que la solidarité sera bien
partagée entre l'état et les et les
collectivités locales ce qui était le
cas l'opération à prague en afghanistan
et ont eu à la halle à la seule à
regarder en tant que ministre
l'intérieur j'ai constaté que souvent
d'ailleurs les collectivités locales
donnait la facture aux préfets et
souvent l'état d'ailleurs à la finance
et
dans la solidarité des collectivités
elles ne disent pas toujours dire que
réclameront à l'état l'argent mais je
constate que parfois ils le réclamaient
je crois que l'état a toujours payé
lorsque c'était en tout cas sa situation
afghane je peux en témoigner
personnellement sur la question bond
compliqué de vous répondre publiquement
monsieur le ministre canet remet mais
c'est une question tout à fait légitime
je n'ai d'ailleurs évoqué moi même ce
matin avec eux avec le comité direction
du ministère de l'intérieur directement
que ce préfet de police et puis je fais
chaque semaine désormais de visu été
préfet parce qu'il appartient mise
l'intérieur d'organiser les crises de
sécurité civile et donc de prévoir donc
j'ai demandé d'abord au préfet un petit
état des lieux notamment de l'état
d'opinion de la population parce que
comme vous sans doute rencontre en plein
de gens dans mon territoire
voilà je pense que l' angoisse autour
des propos du nucléaire est forte
d'abord parce qu'ils payent conflit
potentiel mais aussi parce que nous
avons nos centrales nucléaires et je
crois savoir que dans votre dans notre
département à gravelines d'ailleurs
puisque c'est à 20 km ont distribué des
pastilles jusqu'à 20 qu'elle était
passée diodes les choses avaient été
bien fait je m'en suis d'ailleurs assuré
auprès du préfet nord zone de défense
mais qui lui convenait de le regarder
alors non pas pour annoncer un éventuel
problème mais pour cent préparer voilà
donc à la fois pour l'état de l'opinion
puisque j'ai été surpris par ce ne
seront pas les plus jeunes de nos
compatriotes je sais pas si vous l'avez
constaté vous aussi mais aussi parce
qu'il faut il faut savoir prévoir des
choses au score on est en responsabilité
de la sécurité des français fait
demander un petit état des lieux mais
pour l'instant ce qui m'a été remonté
monsieur de le ministre ne démontrait
pas de difficultés particulières mais
c'est encore un peu trop tôt pour que je
ne puisse vous l'affirmez absolument
complètement en tout cas on s'en occupe
sous le le point
ouais je crois que j'ai répondu mais là
c'est récent même temps à votre question
sur le point de désintox bourse ou des
réseaux sociaux vont le mieux à
l'intérieur n'a pas le pouvoir de
corriger les fausses vérités sur
internet il regrette d'ailleurs
profondément parfois assez à ses dépens
en mai mais il le constate cependant je
crois que la décision européenne prise
sur la fin de rt de spoutnik d'une part
et d'autre part sur la mise en place de
ce qu'on appelle vigie num auprès du
secrétaire général de la défense
nationale qui vise notamment à assurer
que l'élection présidentielle et les
élections législatives se déroulent dans
des conditions de non ingérence d'état
étranger et je crois que le sénat était
consulté évidemment par monsieur
bouillir le secrétaire général à la
défense nationale comme monsieur
l'ornaise montre que la france est
préparée avant la crise à ces possibles
ingérences ça n'empêche pas que chacun
peut dire n'importe quoi
sur les réseaux sociaux et chacun je
crois le constate tous les jours
peut-être est-ce une forme de liberté
peut être venu t-il par fois savoir dire
n'importe quoi que d'avoir des
restrictions de liberté d'expression
doute là je pense que s'ils avaient des
questions parmi les français ce soir son
vivant dictature ou en démocratie ils
ont peut-être dû voir la différence
entre les deux régimes par exemple bon
mais retour en salle des conférences du
sénat vous avez pu suivre en direct
depuis 17h l'audition de gérald darmanin
le ministre de l'intérieur qui était
auditionné par la commission des lois et
la commission des affaires européennes
le ministre qui a défendu le régime de
protection temporaire mis en place dans
les 27 pays membres de l'ue eux il a
évoqué le chiffre de 5000 ukrainien
recensés depuis le début de la guerre
sur le territoire français 321 d'entre
eux ont fait une demande de droit
d'asile c'est la fin de cette édition
spéciale 2 en direct du sénat prochain
rendez-vous dans l'info avec l'info dans
quelques secondes avec sens public
l'émission présentée par thomas hugues
très bonne si des programmes sur public
sénat
[Musique]
revoir ce programme en replay sur
publicsenat.fr
[Musique]
l'actualité parlementaire et politique
continue sur publicsenat.fr
thallion nous y sommes comme tous les
cinq ans la france choisit son président
et comme tous les cinq ans il y aura des
programmes des phrases assassines des
coups bas des renversements dans
l'opinion bref tout ce qui fait le
charme et le piment des campagnes
électorales tout ce qu'on analyse en
détail avec les invités ils ne sont pas
d'accord vous allez le voir et c'est
tant mieux et maintenant 2022 c'est tous
les vendredis à 22h je compte sur vous
amo le
mytho
le monde
[Musique]
bonjour monsieur ange ou je viens pour
faire ma dose de rappel il ya des rendez
vous à ne pas manquer
[Musique]